I think the skip gates scandal was a
great example of how far we are from
being post-racial obviously and I don't
think being post-racial is a worthy
ideal you know I think being colorblind
or being post-racial to me that's kind
of like when people talk about secondary
virginity is something is something that
could never exist and it wouldn't be
worth having if you were able to get it
I mean III think we should be fully
comfortable with seeing someone who's
ever different ethnicity and recognizing
that they are the problem comes when we
make irrational assumptions after we
noticed that he rose I don't want I
don't think any I don't think anyone
wants I like if you forget race and look
at gender I don't think most women want
people to look at them and not notice
whether they are a man or a woman it's
just do you make assumptions about who
they are and what they're capable of
after you notice there a woman you know
I think our our culture and ethnicity
you know for most of us is a big part of
who we are that we take pride in and I
think you know I hope that we're able to
become more racial rather than becoming
post-racial you know and be able to
recognize you know our differences in a
rational way and relish them and
appreciate them and be able to talk
about them frankly instead of hoping to
never notice our differences or discuss
them away I mean to me that's being
afraid of something that's not being
comfortable with it but i think the Skip
gate scandal was certainly a reminder
that there's a lot of work to do both in
our perceptions and in how our
institutions function and I think that
aspect is what unfortunately was lost
and how to gate scandal played out you
know there's been in a way that Obama
has addressed race which I think he's
addressed it extremely well the one flaw
that I felt like was there is there's
been so much of an emphasis on
conversation and on each of us
acknowledging and honoring the other
person's feelings and perspectives and
recognizing where those feelings come
from that we've lost track of how racism
and injustice as an injustice and
inequity also met
fast in ways beyond personal feeling and
personal expression and thoughts there's
also institutional inequity
institutional racism and systemic
inequity and you know those are things
that can't be fixed by conversation and
sharing each other's thoughts and
understanding and I think what you saw
in the Skip gate scandal um skip gates
he made errors in the way that he spoke
Obama made an error in a way that he
spoke but that officer Crowley he didn't
make an error in how he spoke him he
abused his power to arrest somebody and
he was backed up by the institution that
he represents yeah that you know that's
a very widespread problem of police
abusing their power that is not
something you can fix by having the
conversation over a beer there needs to
be changes in how we trained police
officers I need to be changes in the
policies that we enforce you know so
that yeah I mean the people spoke about
officer Crowley as if it was a rogue or
a bad apple but it seems clear to me
that he wasn't a rogue he was he was
someone who provided training on these
issues and was trained in such a way
that he thought it was okay for him to
arrest somebody because he didn't like
their attitude inside their own home and
you saw his institution back him up
after he did that so I think he wasn't
being a bad apple he was doing what he
was trained to do and we need to enact
change on an institutional level to stop
that from happening again because it
happens to thousands of people who don't
have the connections officer gates has
and the consequences are not going to be
a beer with the president you know it's
going to when it escalates is going to
escalate to a Taser or a night stick or
something worse than that and I think
that's something I wish had been focused
on more I mean it's great for us to
encourage conversation but I wish that
President Obama had also taken some time
to note that there are bigger things
than conversation that need to happen
with this issue